meet bounce our 28 years old and a
student in the city of Cologne
today he's trying out the new food loop
app his cell phone chosen which
supermarkets in the vicinity have signed
up for food loop he finds an organic
supermarket right around the corner it
has a number of things on offer that
catch his eye the products listed on
food loop are approaching their sell-by
date many of the foods can still be
eaten even weeks after the date but
retailers aren't allowed to sell them
anymore first bounce pass a jar of
sun-dried tomatoes when he scans the
barcode the app shows him the price and
the ingredients it has 25% off he's also
seen a dairy product that's on special
offer products nearing its sell-by dates
are marked in the morning with the label
the director of the supermarket looks
closer hates being forced to throw away
food the best before they doesn't mean
the food is no longer edible and yet the
foods are just a thrown away we as
retailers are forced to adhere to legal
requirements where sometimes you think
this is crazy like a best before date on
a bag of sugar and mrs. pocket startled
by an athlete Asuka Fulop founder
Christophe mil editions got the idea for
the app while studying in the US I was
working in Starbucks and each night we
had to dump products that were fresh it
came to over a thousand euros a month so
I started taking the products and
selling them to local stores today he
employs nine people by next year he
plans to have covered his outlet costs
it's all possible thanks to sponsorship
money and awards from five different
continents right now he's looking to
expand his customer base
Kaspersky is a Spanish supermarket chain
we're working with him through an EU
sponsorship program to get food loop
working in all 70 of their stores and
what do the potential customers think of
it all yeah I find it helpful and it
saves money too I used to throw food
away but now I'm careful to only buy as
much as I can eat current 9 I'm very
picky when it comes to the best before
date if it's even one day over I
wouldn't eat that Sawa has now made it
to the checkout thanks to the food loop
discount he saved two euros on an
overall bull of just under nine euros so
could he imagine using an app like this
in the future it's a good way of saving
money and hoping to ensure things don't
get thrown away but he'll have to wait a
while the app is still only a pilot
project in Germany the major supermarket
chains have yet to sign up